colin is in minneapolis hi Colin welcome
to the Dave Ramsey show I exciting to
talk to you you too sir what's up so I
just got engaged here about two weeks
ago congratulations thank you and we are
trying to figure out next financially
mm-hmm so both of us have no death we're
both teachers and I come into the
relationship with about Paul Graham
mm-hmm and she comes into the
relationship with about 130,000 and
savings 100,000 in a single stock that's
through a bank and then 250,000 in a
trust fund that can't be touched into
over 30 Wow
and so obviously we're not going to mine
anything until the wedding which is all
set up here for just a couple months
from now good for you trying to figure
out what do we do with that single stock
that's only making about two percent and
we're renting for about a year and so
what do we do after that well I mean you
can either leave that stock there for a
year and then catch it out and use it
for your down payment at that time or
you can cash it out and now I upon
getting married put it into a mutual
fund park it there for a year and use it
at that time to use as a down payment
but I think that's the down payment on
your house your debt-free
you got your emergency fund in place you
guys are in really really good shape
starting out how old are you - 25 Wow
awesome very cool pretty pretty
fortunate and so yes you are we get to
that point
I'm guessing before 30 with the money
this year obviously we'll have a house
paid off that's between 250 and 300 I'm
guessing that trust fund will go growth
at least round 300,000 do you think at
that point where to make more sense to
leave that in there and let it grow and
draw from it as you did being will have
you know probably about a 90 thousand
dollar income between the two of us yeah
I would leave it in investments I
wouldn't leave it in the trust fund I'd
take it out of the trailer on and you
just guys just move it to your
investment broker that's helping you you
know you're smart investor Pro or
whoever
helping you with your investing and I
want you to get complete control of it
at that point but obviously you're being
conservative you're going to paid for
house you got a great income you won't
need it that money will be there to
build wealth and you know and again to
create you know to further this changing
of the family tree that whoever left
this trust fund did wow that's awesome
yeah it's um some little ways that it's
full to see how it'll change the future
here yeah I mean let's just pretend you
went from age 30 to age 60 it never
touched it
thatthat 250,000 is gonna be millions
and millions of dollars sure what would
it make sense move that into I would
just move it into mutual funds that's
what I do with it I only buy two kinds
of investments Colin and I'm not saying
that's the only kind you can buy but
it's number one you put things and you
put money and things you're comfortable
with and you understand okay III
understand and I'm really comfortable
with mutual funds because of the
diversification and the history the
stock market the track record over time
and so I've got a lot of money in that
I'm even more comfortable with real
estate I grew up in the real estate
business I've got my real estate license
since I was 18 I love rental real estate
and making money on real estate it's one
of my side hobbies almost I've got a
degree in real estate so you know that
all of that so we're I in your shoes I'm
probably gonna take that 250 at that
time or 400 or whatever it is and I'm
going to start looking for some rental
property that creates an income but
either that or mutual funds either one
their guts still gonna grow to a lot of
money if you manage it well by the time
you get up in your 60s I mean like
millions and millions and millions of
dollars that's wonderful
that's so cool